how did the project come into the
picture how did you think mr. Cyr rather
there was a film here when I met Leon I
was or have been and still work working
on a KU brick project about his creative
process and when I II met Leon the first
day after we finished filming I realized
I just can't walk away from this even
taking on another project it's
impossible and just you know but yeah I
was amazed by meeting someone in Culver
City that is done all that work it was
always like really mind-blowing and and
so we went from there once you had zero
in that he could be the subject of a
documentary how did you go about he
can't have been easy to secure the
talent to talk about him well first it
was tough to convince Leon to do it
because I learned from doing all the
research and when it before I met Leon
I've already done about six or seven
years of research on Kubrick himself and
so I knew about Leon's role but I
discovered that Leon who is comfortable
talking about Kubrick but he was never
comfortable talking about himself and so
that was a tough one in the beginning I
think we spent about three weeks of
trying to get Leon to feel comfortable
talking about himself and and I think
there was a device in the end that kind
of broke the ice he had so much material
at his home that is you know I apologize
for saying that scattered everywhere all
over his house was just overwhelming and
so I volunteers to organize all his
stuff and put it in nice boxes which is
what you see in the Attic
and but the beauty is I figured it as we
organize everything he will remember and
yes it was he started to look at stuff
and he started to say wow oh my god I
forgot that I've done this and
I've done that and I've done this you're
kidding and it was and we just kept
going and the process of putting
together the interviews again that must
have been also a challenge right from
the producing side of things well one
thing that was really wonderful was we
did want to reach out to a number of
people obviously and Leon gave us a list
tentatively saying well here are some
people who might be willing to talk and
I I don't know if I should speak for you
Lynne with us but I don't think he
necessarily thought people would agree
but they did immediately and we had
people come out to speak to us who have
hesitated to speak in other projects and
there wasn't even a moment's hesitation
they were so happy to do it so yes of
course there was the producing aspect of
having to get in touch with everybody
track people down coordinate it but even
somebody like Danny Lloyd who you know
with Danny in the shining who is a
biology teacher now and rarely goes out
and speaks to anyone we found him and he
just said immediately I would love to so
that was wonderful for us as well as a
lot of the people who had worked with
Leon ins and Stanley we're very very
happy to do it so it was good and how
long was the overall process since you
began with the interviews and then you
did there the camera work the editing
you're a probably a two-person team most
of the time yeah that's it and a little
room up you know in a small room near
the Hollywood Bowl that's basically
what's the two of us yeah it was a
pressure cooker but it was something
that was really beautiful and I just you
know we both feel this but we are so
grateful that Lynne allowed us to tell
his story and that's something we're
always talking about so thank you Anne
should be told
really
because in a number of ways this
documentary is a companion piece to
Harlan Lily and a Hollywood love story
where you get to showcase a talented
people working behind the cameras coming
up with suggestions you know the craft
is a elevates everybody as one of our
the interviewee says yeah and and and I
really felt with this I was and for us
speaking for both of us is it was on a
mission and the mission was to show what
goes on practically every big film how
many people how many people does it take
to make one project and the details and
you do see that Kubrick's films are
always were all about the details and it
was beautiful to find someone there I
mean I'm still amazed when I mean Leon
says in the film that when Kubrick met
him the first when he met Kubrick on the
set of Barry Lyndon and he said get me
an 18 and he said I don't even know what
that is and then the whole journey at
the end he's color correcting his films
that's an achievement for someone that
didn't know what a lens is you know and
he's just done practically everything
with with with Kubrick and in film and
it's a treasure you know so amazing how
was it after all these years a lifetime
of work and and and devotion and and
patience and consistency to be involved
in this field tell us about your
experiences and emotions well it's a bit
weird of course I felt like a I keep 10
13 is it felt it felt like a giant
public therapy sessions oh my god and
but you know the more we sort of went
into and by the way that thing about
tony organizing everything in my house
that's true and they need to come again
just really talk to you about that
but you know it brings it brings forward
so many memories and then so many
wonderful people that you meet in you
know the area we work in you know in
film and in all the creative arts of
course but close to relationships at the
time you're working together with people
who you would never have met before all
kinds of people with all kinds of
different life philosophies and I've
just I think that's an everlasting joy
that I'll have and that's I started to
feel and yeah this is great because now
we're talking about nothing not the star
not the director you know but you know
people who give everything to do with
making a good movie you know if it
possibly can and that for me is is a
jewel the gem in my life it really is
fantastic very good you have made us
better viewers going back to kübra
streams and your contribution thank you
very much